all right early voting begins today in
Georgia for a pivotal U.S Senate race
voters have been responding to the only
debate so far between Democratic senator
Rafael Warnock and Republican Challenger
Herschel Walker this is one of the
contests that could determine control of
the senate for the next two years Nicole
Killian covered Friday's debate and has
been speaking with voters since then
Nicole good morning
hey good morning Michelle it's unclear
if the debate changed any minds but
voters officially get their stay
starting today in fact we've already
seen a number of folks show up here
early this morning and Georgia's
Secretary of State tells us he's bracing
for record turnout
[Music]
it's game day in Georgia tailgaters at
UGA are divided as early voting kicks
off Rafael Warnock is
who we need in the Senate right now
because Herschel Walker has a good heart
you know and uh we believe in you know a
lot of Summer things we visited the
campus where the Heisman Trophy winner
made his name to the field that bears it
in his hometown of Wrightsville and
we're proud that he will be
representative of small town America
near warnock's childhood home in
Savannah voters aren't looking his way
like Tammy Jenkins who went to high
school with him he was always smart I
think he'd been doing a pretty good job
we are joined by a live studio audience
on the debate stage both candidates
appeal to those still undecided this
race is about who's ready to represent
Georgia in the U.S Senate he's for Joe
Biden I'm for Georgia the GOP Challenger
again denied reports he paid for a
woman's abortion but appeared to soften
his stance on a total ban and I say I
support the Georgia heartbeat bill
because that's the bill of the people
from Governor Kim and I said that has
exceptions in it Warnock called out his
past statements he says no exceptions
even in the case of rape
incest
or the life of the mother I think that's
extreme but this exchange went fly role
as the bear clashed Over Law Enforcement
I've never pretended to be a police
officer
and and I've never I've never threatened
a shootout with the police I am with
many police officers you have a prop
that is not allowed sir and we have to
get behind our men and women in blue
both candidates continue to trade barbs
as Walker returned to the campaign Trail
but didn't accept an invitation to a
second debate Sunday leaving an empty
Podium my opponent Herschel Walker is
not here uh and I think that half of
being a senate a senator is showing up
The Walker campaign called last night a
one-sided sham and said that badge
Walker flashed at Friday's debate was an
honorary one from a local Department in
a sign of how critical the stakes are
former president Obama is set to
campaign here in Atlanta later this
month Tony
Nicole Killian Nicole thank you very
much